seit über 50 jahren rocken die rolling
stones die bühnen dieser welt
fast ebenso lang sammelt historiker
feliks apli alles was mit der kultband
zu tun hat
200 sicher sind die gut zu schwimmen
realität bestehe stunde teilige ist nur
noch ein format noch künstlers james
riches jede platte eigentlich nur ein
möglicher standort der usa
auch persönlich mit schweizer tonträger
a3 ist ua platten also die klassische
helfer des 60
momentan ist der chronist der schweizer
pop und rockgeschichte
er war gründungsmitglied und
schlagzeuger der berner band züri west
der musiker nutzte seine kontakte und
trug rund 10.000 schweizer tonträger
zusammen eine einzigartige sammlung
gespickt mit raritäten musikalischen
hier spezielle menschen musik locken
konnte
es ging an comics gesammelt und mit dem
häftling das erste fix und foxi scotland
actros gestorben wo nicht offiziellen
fixie bier und die musik ist denn
einfach so wichtig wo der nutzer
orientiert dass ich mich weniger pro
person kommt gesunden sachen oder wo man
mir den nötigen wieder streitig machen
so legte er den grundstein zu einer
sammlung der superlative felix abriegelt
heute als einer der größten kenner des
tors sein momentaner hingegen fokussiert
auf die schweiz 21
es scheint sehr sanglich spezielles oder
die eher sporadisch möglich sehr gut und
die zweite derartige massen zum foto
vierte bratwurst schrecklich begrenzt
wert praktischen wurde und beim saugen
welches eben um caps letztes stück
schwerter zum beispiel scc sein
momentaner sammelt nicht nur schweizer
bands sondern auch internationale stars
die in der schweiz aufgetreten sind
freut sich anne saxe simons freude und
harmonie schafft insbesondere analysiert
in seinem archiv ist alles vertreten
neben platten auch dokumente und mehrere
tausend konzertplakate
zeugen einer vielfältigen schweizer pop
butter findet morgen gehört des konzepts
große aufregung winterthur findet
informationen zum objekt finden oder
aber es geht darum aktiv zu unterstützen
ein jäger auch ihr felix apli hält jeden
auftritt und jede aufnahme der rolling
stones fest das resultat ist eines der
weltweit besten werkverzeichnis das
sogar von keith richards signiert wurde
die tischtennisplatte des definierten
vor zurückschreckt
graffiti ist zahlen also high end heißt
die dänen krise für ein paar hundert
fällige betrag für die autogramm muss
der sechziger zwischen punktzahl
tausende von objekten aber tausende von
franken jahrzehntelange sammle arbeit
können die zwei enthusiasten jemals
genug
erfolglos das heißt die wird nie fertig
sie reinste horror wenn ich neben auf
das wäre so schlimm